ALLISON HORST: Hi, everyone.
I'm Allison Horst.
I'm an assistant teaching
professor at the Bren
School at UC Santa Barbara.
And over the past
year, I've also
been RStudio's
artist in residence.
In this talk, I'm really
excited to share with you
some of the motivation behind my
R artwork and also some lessons
I've learned from the R
community along the way.
To get started,
I want to ask you
to think about what did it feel
like for you the first time you
started learning R. Maybe you
are one of the lucky ones where
all you felt was
happiness and excitement
and you knew this was going to
be an awesome tool to learn.
But for many people
who are learning
R or code for the first time,
that's not the reaction.
There can be some
confusion at the idea
of learning this new language.
There can be some
frustration, maybe you
are already happily working
in another language,
and you're looking at R thinking
like, what is the kakapo?
I want my pandas back.
Maybe you are feeling
frustrated as you try to get up
this steep learning curve.
Or maybe you weren't
even expecting
to have to learn how
to code, and you're
looking at R just having a
meltdown because it's something
that's so completely new.
And all of these feelings are
pretty common for learners,
and this isn't unique to R. A
recent Google search for why
is coding so dot,
dot, dot reveals
that a lot of the top searches
related to why is coding so
are not totally positive.
Why is coding so hard,
so boring, complicated,
frustrating, difficult,
hard to learn,
confusing, and stressful?
And yes, mixed in here there's
some good ones like, why
is coding so important?
And why is coding so fun?
That might be an artifact of
this being part of my search
results.
But the overall takeaway is
that for a lot of learners,
R and learning to
code in general
can feel a little
bit intimidating
and maybe not like a
totally happy place.
And not only can it feel
a little bit intimidating,
but it's also a big energy
and time investment.
There are so many
things to learn
to get started in R and
with coding in general,
and there's always
something new coming out.
For those of us who are
happily working in R,
maybe we are this green
monster on the right where
we see new tutorials and
new resources or packages
coming out every
day, and we are so
excited knowing that it can
be something useful for us
to learn and use.
But we can imagine that
for learners, who are just
trying to get up this steep
learning curve, seeing all
of those new things
coming out all
the time could be a
little bit daunting.
So what can we do when
something is hard to learn
and we're asking a learner
to make an investment?
One thing that we
can do is we can
put in a little
bit of extra work
to help something
that originally
doesn't look that appetizing
feel a little bit more
appetizing.
For example, if we know
that vegetables contain
a lot of really great
nutrients, but it's
hard to convince
somebody to eat them,
maybe we can dress it up
to look like a cute bug
to make it more likely
that they will invest
in eating those vegetables.
And people are already
doing this in code.
For example, Julia
Evans' zines that
explained a lot of really
important basics in CSS
and Git, and bash are a
really useful teaching tools
because they provide
information for learners,
but they also make it
look very welcoming.
These look like a thing that
I would want to engage with.
And I found myself
wondering when
I was teaching courses in R to
graduate students, most of who
had never coded before, do
those resources exist in R?
Are there nice, welcoming,
engaging illustrations
that I can include in
my course materials?
There would be a welcoming
entryway for graduate students
to learn new functions
and packages.
Because what I found was
that I would be up there
in the front of a
class so excited
to introduce an
amazing new function
and on the screen
behind me would
be a screenshot of the
documentation, which contains
a lot of really
important information
that's going to be essential
moving forward, but maybe
was not the most inspiring
first interaction
that a student could have
with a new function, which
made me think, yes,
there is a place
to create engaging
artwork that dresses up
R a little bit to make it look
more inviting and welcoming.
And over the past
year, that has been
my entire goal as RStudio's
artist in residence,
has been to create useful
and engaging illustrations
that welcome users to
explore, teach, and learn
about new packages
and functions in R.
And they will still have to
go on to eat their vegetables
and learn those hard skills,
but the first interaction
could be something that is fun
and positive and welcoming.
So for example, instead of
their first view of mutate
being a screenshot
of the documentation,
maybe instead their first
interaction with mutate
could be seeing these
helpful X-Men monsters
adding a new column to
an existing data frame.
And over the past
year, I've not only
been creating many illustrations
as a welcoming interaction
with different functions
and packages in R,
but I've also created
illustrations showing
general data science
principles and concepts
and also a whole
bunch of hex stickers.
But what I want
to talk about now
is what I've learned from the
R community over the past year.
And these have been really
important lessons for me
as an artist and as a
data science teacher.
And the first thing
that the R community
has helped me to embrace is
that cute and credible artwork
coexist.
Just like Bailey,
the golden retriever,
is sitting here looking totally
credible and professional
while he develops his
R package, he also
is looking very adorable.
And that can happen
with artwork too.
And even though I knew
this, even though I
knew that making and
including artwork
could be really useful for
effective communication making
slides more engaging,
connecting to learners
and clarifying concepts,
showing empathy, lowering
learning barriers, I just
really love doing it.
And also including artwork
into course materials
can really help
students understand
that, yes, creativity
and artwork have
a place in science.
Even though I knew
those things, there
was always this little gremlin
on my shoulder saying, OK,
you can lean hard into
the artwork for R&amp;D
to science education,
but just know
that that might actually damage
your credibility as a data
scientist.
And there is a
turning point when
I realized that this
was totally unfounded.
And that was when
Hadley Wickham asked
me to create a series of
illustrations for an upcoming
talk he was giving called The
Joy of Functional Programming.
And I was so excited
because I knew this
was going to be like a big talk,
a really awesome opportunity
to share artwork.
And I was expecting that because
this was a highly professional,
important, advance
talk that this was
going to be maybe some
sleek designs I was creating
to go along with the slides.
And to my absolute
delight, Hadley,
when I asked him what style
he was thinking about,
he responded that he was
thinking about these monsters
being included in this series.
And I tried to play it
cool and be like, oh, yeah,
of course the monsters
would belong in there.
But in my heart I was
just like, oh my gosh!
The monsters have
made it, and this
is like cute artwork being
invited to be at the top level
talks in R and data science.
Not only were the
monsters invited,
but they were going to be
baking cupcakes in this series.
So really capturing for me this
idea that cute and credible
are not at odds with each
other, that including cute
illustrations can be a
really powerful teaching
tool at any level.
I think the one example that
captures this so perfectly is
the certified trainer badge from
RStudio, which is one adorable,
but two is the badge that's used
when the certified trainers get
their certification,
which are some
of the top educators
in the R community.
And this has been a theme
that has been reinforced
with pretty much every
interaction I've had,
both with RStudio
and in the R community
is that there is a
refreshing lack of ego
about what educational
materials look like.
And everyone is always just
welcoming and encouraging
more approachable
educational resources.
What that means is
that, while I started
with this little
gremlin on my shoulder
questioning my credibility
and bringing a lot of doubt
into my mind,
what I have now is the
same gremlin which is now
encouraging me
and always asking,
can I actually make this
more approachable or cuter
somehow?
The second big thing
that I've learned
from the R community
over the past year
is that art truly can be a
useful teaching and learning
tool that helps learners
engage with and remember
new functions.
An example of the type of
artwork I've been creating
is this illustration for
the string squish function.
And the job of string squish
is to remove leading, trailing,
and repeated interior
white space from strings.
And here we see
these four monsters
who are working together
to squish this string.
And in doing so are
ejecting excess white space.
This combination of having text
and something verbally explain
and also an illustration showing
what that function is doing I
think is a powerful combination
that can help with retention.
An example of this
happening in the wild
is this illustration
that was trying
to help people
remember to use ungroup
if they have used
group by previously.
We have in the
forefront two monsters
who are at a birthday party, and
you could see that one of them
has received this
amazing gift of group by.
But more importantly
for this illustration,
we can see in the background
this other little monster
holding ungroup group as a
gift who is just so hoping
they're going to be included.
And the reaction to
this illustration
was exactly what I was
hoping it would be,
which is an emotional reaction
ensuring that people will not
forget ungroup.
For example, some
of the responses
were, "I'm so sad for that
little bub being left out.
I'm always going to remember
this when using ungroup.
I'm never going to look
down on ungroup again."
And my favorite
one is someone who
said they were just able
to help someone else solve
a problem because they
remembered the super cute
and somewhat sad drawing.
I think this really reflects
that artwork can be a way
to engage people's
emotions that helps
them remember important skills.
Art can also be really
useful in helping to clarify
big or vague concepts.
For example, I recently
worked with Julia Lowndes
on a series of
illustrations to try
to portray the
benefits of working
with tidy data, an organizing
data in a tidy data structure.
And what this
illustration is showing
is that if you have data sets
that are all in tidy structure
that you can use the same
tools in similar ways
across data sets.
But in contrast, if
we have untidy data.
What that means is we
oftentimes are hacking together
unique tools to deal
with unique data sets
in their own unique ways, which
is challenging and tedious
and makes it hard to
collaborate with people.
So I think that this
series was really
useful in taking some
kind of big picture ideas
about the benefits of tidy
data and capturing them
in a way that is more
memorable visually.
Artwork can also
make things that
are kind of intimidating
for learners,
feel a little bit more
friendly, and provide
a more welcoming entry way.
For example, for loops
usually aren't the thing
that learners are the
most excited to learn.
But they're especially
intimidating
when it's just like sequences
of numbers and the code
coming in and out that's a
little bit daunting to look at.
So what if instead there
could be a vector that's
actually a parade of monsters.
And in going through
that for loop,
depending on the
shape of the monster,
they are either assigned
to get sunglasses or a hat,
and then what we can
see is the outcome
is the result of each
of those monsters going
through that for loop and
either getting their sunglasses
or hat.
And the third thing
that I've learned
is that art can be an incredibly
powerful tool for creating
supportive communities.
As a landscape
painter originally, I
did not understand how
important this could be.
But art can be a way to directly
show support for learners.
It can show empathy.
For example, here we see
this little bud who is just
needing to take a minute.
So it can be really
useful for showing empathy
when learners are
maybe struggling
or feeling alone in the
struggles that they're facing.
It can be a way to
engage the community
by creating activities
that include artwork.
For example, with
these coloring book
illustrations of
"R session aborted"
and everyone's favorite
"object of type closure
is not subsettable."
And it can also just
be a really cool way
that different groups
and communities
can represent
themselves and make
other people feel included.
The most common way
that we see this
is in the many hex
stickers that exist
that different groups,
organizations, and even
packages are used to
represent themselves.
And I had no idea before joining
the R community the power
that a 2 inch by 1.73 inch
hexagonal design could have.
And this is something
that I was so
amazed by is the support
and demand for hex stickers
that I think really reflects
how excited people are
to have something that they
can put on their computer
or whatever to represent
themselves and the groups
that they're a part of.
So in summary, what I've
learned over the past year
and that has been reinforced
by so many people in the R
community is that
creative contributions
can make coding and
R a more welcoming
or even just a more fun
place for learners and users
at all levels.
And knowing that what can
we do to create and support
more art in R?
The first thing is we
can find ways to support
creative contributions.
So whatever level
makes sense for you,
how can you support artists
and creative contributors?
Just by watching this
talk you are supporting
creative contributions.
But you can also include artwork
in your teaching resources.
You can like or share artwork
that's posted on Twitter.
Whatever level
makes sense for you,
I guarantee that
your support will
be meaningful for
an artist and will
make them want to create more.
The second is you
could think about ways
to more formally collaborate
with creative contributors.
For example, can you
contract an artist
to add something
to your resources?
Can you write an artist into a
grant that you're working on?
Or can you create an
artist-in-residence program
where I guarantee you will
have your work reflected
in a way that's really
engaging for people
who might not have otherwise
known about or engaged with it?
And finally, I would ask you
to think about ways that you
can be a creative contributor.
So what do you do
that you might be
able to share with
the community?
We already have this
amazing community of people.
And so many of them are creating
and sharing incredible artwork
and fabric and R generated
designs, 3D renderings,
amazing graphic
designs made in ggplot,
and so many other things.
And we should think about
what other types of artwork
or creative contributions
would we want to invite.
And the answer should
be all of them.
Baking, music and
sculpture, dance.
There is someone
in the world who
can do the perfect interpretive
dance of pivot_longer
and pivot_wider, and I
want to experience that.
Memes, design, poetry, art
in activities, and so much
more so that we can
be creating artwork
and creative contributions
that engage and resonate
with every different R user who
we would want to feel included.
And sometimes I think
there's this pressure
if you're thinking about
what can I contribute?
There can sometimes
be pressure to feel
like there has to be
some learning outcome
or somebody has to have a
take away or a new skill.
And I encourage you to
remember that making
someone feel a little bit
happier while they're trying
to learn something hard is
an absolutely great reason
to create and share your art.
One experience that
I had with this
recently was I was having
kind of a rough day.
I was mope scrolling
through Twitter,
and I happened to come across
Jacqueline Nolis' picture of the R
pancakes that she had created.
And this didn't solve
my coding problems,
this didn't write
my lecture for me,
but what it did do is it
made me exclaim, R pancakes!
And then I just continued on
my day a little bit happier
because R pancakes had
existed in the world.
So to wrap up, no, art
is not the solution
to tech's problems,
especially related
to inclusion and welcoming.
Unless we're talking about
this whale tail sculpture that
is literally saving a
train that's gone off
the end of the
tracks, art is not
going to save tech,
which is why I'm
so grateful for the
many organizations
groups, individuals, and
initiatives just some of which
are shown here that have been
doing this hard work to make R
more welcoming for more
users since before I even
started using R.
So while art is not
the solution, I
hope that it can be a
supporting piece that
helps those efforts by making
the entire landscape of R,
which is already so vibrant
even a little bit sunnier.
I look forward to
talking with many of you
about all the
different ways we can
contribute more creative
things to the R community.
Thank you.